[Música]
os habéis preguntado alguna vez cómo los
seres humanos
apreciamos o percibimos el paso del
tiempo
seguramente cada uno tenga una respuesta
porque nuestra apreciación es diferente
es posible que alguno al oír la pregunta
por estas cosas haya pensado en albert
eisntein gracias que en base a su teoría
hemos hecho cotidiano el concepto de
relatividad y nos permitimos
interpretaciones acerca de la idea de
que el tiempo no es absoluto sino
relativo
bueno yo no sé de física nada de física
pero a mí esto de lo absoluto de lo
relativo me suena a subjetivo y veréis
los artistas plásticos como yo vivimos
muy conscientemente la subjetividad
nuestro trabajo consiste en observar
interiorizar y transformar a través de
la estética concretando en un objeto
artístico en mi caso esculturas el
resultado de nuestra observación por eso
mi obra se nutre desde mi subjetividad y
se expresa a través de mi punto de vista
desde ahí
hablaré con vosotros compartiendo
algunas de mis impresiones respecto al
aprovechamiento del tiempo
desde mi punto de observación como
artista plástico como escultor
me gusta explorar el papel que juega el
ser humano entendido como persona dentro
de la sociedad
por eso en mis esculturas los personajes
habitan escenas y éstas se desarrollan
en un contexto porque entiendo nuestra
realidad dentro del marco social sin
embargo hay algo que me llama la
atención y es que no estoy segura
bueno me pregunto no estoy segura de si
esta serie de normas de convivencia que
hemos establecido como válidas como
deseables no habrán llegado a relegar la
capacidad individual del ser de la
persona
es una pregunta amplia que abarca muchos
aspectos de la vida pero bueno de todos
ellos me llama la atención uno en
concreto y se refiere al grado de
frustración o estrés que algunos
sentimos respecto al aprovechamiento de
nuestra de nuestro tiempo
seguramente os habéis dado cuenta de que
existe una aceleración sobre las cosas
una aceleración progresiva en
prácticamente todos los aspectos de la
vida pero quizá con más énfasis en
aquellos que revierten sobre la sociedad
trabajo productividad consumo todo tiene
que ser para allá y de la manera más
efectiva posible
parece que la inmediatez se ha
convertido en un valor
además hay cosas que has de realizar
logros que debes conseguir sí o sí y tu
responsabilidad como ciudadano es
cumplir en tiempo correcto y concreto lo
que se demanda de ti así que
quien no ha sentido alguna vez que su
tiempo está pre gastado que no somos
dueños de nuestro tiempo
cuando alguien pasa esto sentir que se
me escapa el tiempo que no lo controlo
que no tengo
sensación de haberlo aprovechado
pues bueno la verdad es que me viene a
la mente esa idea de que el tiempo no es
relativo
y el fin está esta idea de la
relatividad del tiempo quizás sea un
poquito más palpable en determinados
momentos son los buenos que son momentos
totalmente admitidos son los momentos
que llamamos tiempos muertos los tiempos
muertos a mi parecer son momentos que
bueno que se supone que estás ocupado
pero en realidad no le estás tanto
incluso puedes no estarlo
son momentos sutiles que pueden pasar
desapercibidos son momentos
bueno que nos permiten hacernos un
poquito más dueños de nuestro tiempo
veréis hay bastantes tiempos que podemos
llamar muertos a mí los que más me
gustan son estos que dedicamos a esperar
a trasladarnos de un lugar a otro en
este sentido los medios de transporte
son perfectos porque en el acto de
trasladarnos de un lugar a otro la
mayoría de las veces también implica
espera eso y es en esos momentos en los
que puedes aprender el tiempo hacerte un
poquito más dueño de ese tiempo
en estos medios en los medios de
transporte como os decía que son estos
espacios donde yo creo que puedes
combinar el esperar con el trasladarse
de un lugar a otro
son espacios que son realmente
interesantes para mí porque me llama la
atención su atmósfera su arquitectura su
ambiente cómo nos desarrollamos cómo nos
desenvolvemos en ellos
la simbología que conllevan
así que bueno pues se han convertido en
protagonistas de bastantes de mis piezas
habéis reparado en la cantidad de cosas
que se puede hacer esperando en un
aeropuerto o en un andén bueno aparte de
aburrirnos que eso también es importante
a veces
podemos relajar la mente observando el
alrededor esas bandas transportadoras de
maletas son hipnóticas cuando llevas
horas de vuelo
también podemos aprender a disfrutar de
nuestra soledad disfrutar de nuestra
soledad es todo un reto
podemos establecer un diálogo
enriquecedor bueno si es mejor
enriquecedor con nosotros mismos porque
es el fin cuántas veces nos ha
sorprendido esa imagen reflejada en el
cristal del metro verdad como que
impacta pero establecer ese diálogo es
importante podemos
leer
aprender
pensar con calma en nuestras cosas
podemos observar a los demás se aprende
muchísimo observando a los demás
el caso es que reflexionando sobre estos
tiempos muertos caí en la cuenta de que
siempre se desarrollan en estos lugares
de tránsito creados para no ser
habitados que definió como no lugares el
antropólogo marco y
y bueno pues por analogía pues bueno
pues podemos llamar no tiempos a estos
tiempos muertos de nuestra existencia
donde nadie espera nada de nosotros
donde supuestamente no tenemos que tener
ningún tipo de productividad porque ya
está rentabilizado simplemente por el
acto del traslado o la espera
pero hay un detalle que me llamó la
atención y es que
generalmente cuando estamos en un nuevo
lugar y en un no tiempo estamos rodeados
de personas que no conocemos y esto es
interesante porque vamos a ver si yo me
pongo en situación y pienso cómo me
siento cuando estoy en un no lugar bueno
pues es un espacio que no me ancla no
tengo ningún tipo de atadura estoy en mi
no tiempo nadie espera nada de mí
perfecto ningún tipo de exigencias
fenomenal y además
ser apegos porque no conozco a nadie
nadie me conoce a mí pues yo no sé
vosotros pero ya lo imaginarme esa
situación me invade una sensación
liberadora de anonimato
bastante importante
mi experiencia es que cuando lo de fuera
nos sitúa en una condición de anonimato
nos permite volver la vista hacia
adentro y desde nuestro centro desde
nuestro pensamiento tenemos la libertad
de utilizar ese momento a nuestro antojo
podemos hacer lo que queramos podemos
dejarnos llevar esos lugares amables del
recuerdo
podemos soñar podemos ilusionarnos
proyectar nuestros deseos
podemos
preguntarnos acerca de las cosas
curiosear
o también podemos contemplar sin pesar
el paso del tiempo
esto quizás no es tan fácil sobre todo
cuando los acontecimientos nos
sorprenden recientemente todos hemos
vivido un gran tiempo muerto totalmente
inesperado el gran parón que hemos
vivido este último año no se ha
desarrollado en 1 lugar sino en nuestras
propias casas ha sido algo nuevo para
todos pero cada uno guardamos una
vivencia un poso una sensación diferente
bueno sabemos todos sabemos que el
recuerdo y la memoria vienen
condicionados por las emociones por la
atención por la importancia que damos a
la situación vivida
y bueno pues podemos decir en este
sentido que son relativos como el tiempo
mi experiencia de esta vivencia pues me
ha servido para
y poner de relevancia el papel que juega
la subjetividad
[Música]
en mis recuerdos
darme cuenta de que es más importante
para mi bienestar como recuerdo los
acontecimientos como me afectan que los
acontecimientos en sí
me hace tener claro el poder de la
subjetividad no para alterar hechos sino
para ejercer una posición y determinar
una actitud frente a lo acontecido
recuerdo que ortega y gasset en su
concepto de realidad radical expone
que existe una relación directa y
necesaria entre subjetividad y mundo
o lo que es lo mismo entre yo y
circunstancias dice que es una relación
que se construye en el tiempo lo llama
el vivir
interesante verdad
cuando observo cuando observo mi vivir
cuando observo mi vivir desde
desde mi yo desde mi subjetividad
de alguna manera me adueñó de ese tiempo
y desde mi posición de dueña
puedo dar justa importancia a los
valores de evaluación establecidos por
la sociedad pero también pone en
relevancia los propios respecto al
aprovechamiento del tiempo
la subjetividad
tiene la capacidad de alterar el tiempo
y desde la memoria establecer en el
recuerdo emociones y sentimientos que
van a influir directamente la
construcción de nuestro futuro puedo
construir mi vivir siendo consciente de
quién soy yo en mis circunstancias
el tiempo no es absoluto el tiempo es
relativo y su percepción totalmente
subjetiva
tenemos la posibilidad de hacernos
dueños de nuestro tiempo podemos
disfrutar nuestros tiempos
yo espero confío que la apreciación que
tengáis de este tiempo que hemos
compartido haya sido de un tiempo
aprendido del que podáis guardar en la
memoria un grato recuerdo gracias
[Aplausos]